[Music]
[Music]
where is it
safe do better where did you get it why
would i tell you
fury gave it to you why what's on it i
don't know
stop lying i only act like i know
everything rogers
i bet you knew fury hired the pirates
didn't you
what makes sense the ship was dirty fury
needed a way in so do you i'm not gonna
ask you again
i know who killed fury
most of the intelligence community
doesn't believe he exists the ones that
do call him the winter soldier
he's credited with over two dozen
assassinations in the last 50
years so he's a ghost story five years
ago i was escorting a nuclear engineer
out of iran
somebody shot out my tires near odessa
we lost control
went straight over a cliff i pulled us
out but the winter soldier was there
i was covering my engineer so he shot
him straight through me
soviet slug no rifling
bye bye bikinis yeah i bet you look
terrible
now
going after him is a dead end i know
i've tried
like you said he's a ghost story
let's find out what the ghost wants
you